هذا ودانت حركه النهضه الحكم القاضي بسجن
رئيسها راشد الغنوشي لمده عام فيما تعرف
بقضيه الطاغوت وداعت النهضه في بيان الى
الافراج الفوري عن رئيسها وقالت ان الحكم
الصادر بحقه حكم سياسي ظالم وقالت الحركه
في بيان الى راشد الغنوشي معتقل لتعبيره
عن رايه على خلفيه تصريح مزور على حد
وصفها
بدورها قالت جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس
ان الحكم الصادر بحق راشد الغنوشي رئيس
حركه النهضه يثبت ان السلطه لم تستطع
اثبات اي اعمال ماديه مجرمه في حقه انا لا
احد من المعارضين مهما كان موقعها او
انتمائه في مامن من مصادره حريته والزجي
به في السجن اضافت جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
بيان ان الحكم على الغنوشي وايداع اكثر من
20 شخصيه سياسيه بالسجن دون حجه او تبرير
ليس سوى كيل تهم جزافا والانحراف بالسلطه
والقانون